can somebody
yep yep
yeah okay great
thanks alex was that you
yes hey alon
okay hi hey everyone
okay so welcome to session eight of itcs
and
[Music]
it's weaker okay okay recording started
great
um okay so that's session eight
um this is again this is going to be a
session of show talks
itcs has this tradition
where usually the session chair
gives some overview of the papers
and we have a very short session it's
one hour for five papers so i'm not
gonna talk a lot i'm really gonna like
talk 10 seconds about each paper okay
just to make sure that everybody's
here and intrigued and stay for the
entire session
um and then we'll have a 10 minute talk
by each also
including questions and some
two three minutes for a full buffer time
um
okay
so we have five papers
and
the first paper
uh i'm not going to say all the authors
but it's going to be interactive
interaction to several compilers for
secure computation
and for each paper
i tried to ask
a question which what is the question
that the paper asks
in a kind of language that maybe the
author of the paper didn't
you know allow themselves to ask
okay but i can do this for them so
really they ask here i think this is a
question actually they do write in the
paper in this example but what is the
price of security i think this is like a
great premise wallpaper a great question
okay we want security but at what the
price i actually have one paper where i
ask the same question and you can ask
this in many different contexts and here
they say okay we have
some
a protocol that allows me to compute
something in a non-secure manner okay
and this protocol has some communication
complexity and now what is the price of
taking this this protocol and making
sure that it's secure
okay they will secure on the npc
in the in in the mpc sense
okay so this is paypal number one
um i think justin is gonna present this
paper if i remember correctly
yep
okay okay
okay
so um
paper number two
uh so we have one mpc paper two
encryption papers and two hash
functionals so this is the hash function
paper
a locality preserving hashing for shifts
okay with connections to cryptography
and
this is a very nice premise of the hash
functions that they maintain some
locality property
and this allows you to do something like
encrypt a message such that only people
that are near you and can decrypt the
message
or the way i like to put it like what is
an encryption encryption
is something that crypto allows you to
simulate uh a box with a you know with a
key and a look right
so this is physically what we think of
and this is
what crypto allowed us to do
mathematically and here the question is
can crypto mathematically implement
whispering
okay can it implement that i whisper
something and only somebody somebody
near me can hear it
okay so this is a paper number two
and the third
paper is a
pre-constrained the encryption
ah the second paper i think of heart is
talking right
yeah assignment yes
thank you for okay
preconceived
encryption
um
so this is one of the
encryption papers let's say
talk about this setting of encryption
which we have a master key and then we
have the other keys
okay maybe functional encryption i think
is there one good example
we have a master key but then i can
derive
you know secondary keys that can only
decrypt for some function
and the
question here really
is
do i trust the person with the master
key
or maybe do not do it and how can i
you know reduce the trust the the the
trust that i need to give to somebody
that contains the master key okay so how
can i do some something that's
pre-constrained even for the master okay
okay and this is really reduces the
power of the setup phase and i think
this is a very very important
and i believe pabanjam will be giving to
talk i didn't see him see him here
before
um
okay
uh
the
fourth
um
paypal is lattice inspired broadcast
encryption okay and success in
ciphertext policy abe
um so
um
i satisfied here is going to give the
talk
so broadcast encryption is this
a very very nice primitive
where you want to encrypt a message okay
and there's a big audience every
audience has a public and private key
and i want some sub-population so some
subset of the of the audience to to get
my message
and the question is how can i do this
efficiently
and
it's very easy to do this inefficiently
if i just encrypt every person you know
i just double my encryption
you know for every person separately
um but of course we don't want to do
that
and
there's a long line of works but
essentially all these walks
do not get post quantum security
um maybe except for obfuscation i think
i'm not sure
um
but
in particular they're not like this
based
and you could ask well what does the
quantum physics have against broadcast
encryption okay why do quantum physics
they really don't allow us to do this
broadcast in encryption and even after
you see speakers talk you'll see that um
the problem is really uh far from being
being solved actually i think this is
very interesting
um
the last paper
is about correlation interactable hash
functions via shift hiding
so um this is another paper and a long
line of papers
that are trying to implement correlation
factor hash functions mainly for the
purpose of doing a future meal
okay so we want to do this uh future
meal a paradigm but we don't want to
assume around the molecule okay so if we
have around the molecule we put pretty
much nowhere
for what protocols we can apply the
theatre mu transform
but we want to do this like with a
concrete you know hash function that we
can implement under some standard
assumption
and really i
like all these works because
they really
are asking you know can we bridge this
big gap between
the concrete hash functions that we have
and random overkills and i think this is
like
a very nice research uh direction and
every progress you know from this end
and every focus from this and getting us
closer and closer together
and one day maybe we'll understand like
you know exactly what properties we need
for every application that allows us to
you know replace the random organ
yeah okay so that's the the last stock
with no further ado and we'll start with
the first talk with uh justin
just in justin
welcome to show
okay
all right thank you for the nice
introduction
and for
um
giving just kind of a
brief summary of what this talk is about
so in this talk we're
worried about secure comp uh multi-party
computation where the parties all
provide a private input and then get the
output the security guarantee we want of
course is that no input or no
information about the input is revealed
except for the output
we're also concerned with the setting
where all but one party can be corrupted
there's been a lot of work on over the
years on optimizing the communication
complexity of secure computation
yao's original garbled circuit
construction scales with the size of
both inputs
recently
works have studied alistar bob optimized
protocols which have a communication
which is independent of one party's
input
however these are only limited to
two-party computation protocols though
they are constant-round protocols
another approach to minimizing
communication complexity is to compile
an insecure protocol into a secure
protocol using fully homomorphic
encryption
the communication ends up being
proportional to the communication of the
insecure protocol but incurs a
multiplicative polynomial blow up in the
security parameter lambda
and for certain
computations the communication can then
be independent of both inputs depending
on the insecure protocol being compiled
another downside of this approach is
that it adds two additional rounds
in this work we're focused on optimizing
that second approach
and trying to be able to
remove the multiplicative communication
blob as well as the extra rounds
our end goal is to be able to lift
results from the communication
complexity literature directly into the
secure computation setting without
paying a significant price in terms of
interaction
of course not all functions can be
computed using less communication than
the size of the inputs
however a rich class of functions can be
for example let's consider two chess
playing ais the ai's themselves might be
quite large but playing chess only
requires communicating the next move
and this example of course naturally
extends to other combinatorial games
there are many of more examples which
can also be found in the communication
complexity literature
for our first result we start by
considering semi-honest adversaries in
the common reference string model
semi-honest adversaries follow the
protocol but try to learn extra
information by examining the messages
and in the common reference string model
uh parties start with a string which is
sampled by a trusted party
assuming the hardness of circular
learning with errors we achieve a
communication complexity which is
asymptotically the communication
complexity of the insecure protocol
being compiled
plus some additional overhead terms
you might notice that we do incur a
polynomial blow up with respect to the
security parameter lambda in terms of
the last message
depth of the output circuit and size of
the output uh overcoming this
overhead without adding additional
rounds has been shown to require some
form of program obfuscation
for the case of two parties
our compiler is perfectly round
preserving but for the case more general
case of m parties
we do have to add an additional round
however by additionally assuming
extractable witness encryption and
succinct non-interactive arguments of
knowledge
we can get around this extra round
and get a perfect round preservative
compiler even for the
more general multi-party case this does
come at a slight cost to communication
overhead
once we've answered these two questions
a natural next question is whether or
not we can lift these results into the
plane model and get security against
malicious adversaries
we show the answer to this to be yes if
we additionally assume simulation
extractable snarks
this does incur a polynomial blow up in
the size of the second messages
but no other blow up no other message is
blown up this way
additionally due to some lower bound for
the setting
the protocol takes a minimum of four
rounds
at the heart of our communication
improvements is a construction of rate
one multi-key fully homomorphic
encryption which was not previously
known
and as a building block we also
construct rate one multi-key linearly
homomorphic encryption
the multi-key property allows parties to
merge their keys instead of computing
one master secret key as in a
normal fully homomorphic encryption
based compiler
avoiding this extra computation saves a
few rounds
the rate one property ensures that the
encrypted messages have roughly the same
size as the ciphertext messages so that
the encrypted protocol does not get
significantly become significantly
larger
for the last few minutes the talk i'm
going to give a high level overview of
our rate one multi-key linearly
homomorphic encryption construction
since that's a major stepping stone on
the way to rate one multi-key fully
homomorphic encryption
our starting point is regiv's encryption
scheme which is modified to pack many
messages into a single ciphertext
the slide of course is missing many
details since there's not much time
but the important bits are that the
messages are represented as a vector the
secret key consists of a matrix s the
ciphertext consists of two components c1
and c2
and decryption is linear where we take
the second ciphertext component minus s
times the first ciphertext component
the first step to achieving rate one
multi-key linearly homework encryption
of course is to enable the multi-key
aspect
the general idea behind
enabling linear evaluations on
ciphertext which are encrypted under
different secret keys is to keep the
first component of each ciphertext
and then combine the second components
then we can do decryption similarly to
the original process simply by pairing
the first components with their
respective secret keys
now you might notice that
this does increase the size of the
ciphertext evaluated ciphertexts will
scale with the number of keys involved
however if you keep the number of keys
the same you can combine arbitrarily
many ciphertexts under those keys
without increasing the message size
in order to achieve rate one even with
this handicap we observe that a larger
message space amortizes the cost of
computing on keys
this is particularly useful when we're
compiling protocols whose messages scale
in size with the number of parties
involved
the second tool that we're going to use
in order to achieve rate one is a
ciphertext compression algorithm
from burkerski at all which crucially
relies on the linear decryption process
of the multi-kilolineally homomorphic
encryption
then to achieve rate 1 we combine both
of these
tools with some careful parameter
choices
if you found this talk interesting
please check out the full version and
thanks for listening
okay thank you very much justine
uh we have like a manifold questions any
questions
okay so justin thank you again and we'll
just move on to the second talk
um
okay so uh oh had are you giving the
talk
yeah yes can you hear me
yeah we can hear you
and you're on
great
so the story begins when alice and bob
go get to new
york and they want to meet up
we all know that it might be a
challenging task to find each other
so one solution to the problem is if
alice and bob seek for the statue of
liberty
find the relative locations to
to the statue and
and then they can compute the relative
location by subtracting the two vectors
now this solution is of finding each
other as two problems first we do not
always have a notable object
such as the statue of liberty
and second even if we do have such a
notable object it takes a linear time to
find it
so we seek for a general and efficient
method for communicating relative
locations of two people
for this we introduced the concept of
locality preserving action for shifts or
lphs in short
which roughly speaking is uh
we are given a string or two-dimensional
string in the
in in the previous context and you need
to find a distinguished location inside
this this string or this map
so we say that the function h
from strings to locations
is a d delta lphs
if h makes reads
d bits
from the input
and moreover if
if the probability is that h on a string
does not equal to
the h of the string shifted by one
a plus one is smaller than delta that is
the probability that
the
distinguished location is not the same
in
x and shifted variant is small
this definition has several variants for
example you may ask why
why we consider an average input
x why not insist that for every input
we have that
[Music]
we find we find the distinguished
location inside this input
so in the paper we showed that
[Music]
that
[Music]
that
we can implement the worst case lphs
using an average case lphs
so
for simplicity in this stock we assume
random string x
moreover there is the
i didn't specify
whether the shifts are cyclic
or
or the shifts are cyclic that is we take
the string chop one bit from from one of
the sides and insert a new bit
again the two variants are
similar and
in this stock we are going to assume as
i click shifts
and moreover
in the previous slide we discussed
one-dimensional lphs
and we can also
define two-dimensional rphs in which we
want that
the the shifting property world both
when we shift our
map or string
to
downwards or to
go to these sides
so you mean the input is a matrix and
you you move all the rows
yes in the same way exactly exactly yes
okay so
there are several applications to a good
constructions of lphas which we show in
the paper
and
the our first application is algorithmic
in this
in this setting we are given
several input strings
in pre-process time
and then
[Music]
after pre-processing them
we
were given
one string at a time
and we need to find the closest string
in our uh
in the
in the pre-processed string
that is closest to it in in inside the
shift metric
of course there are things that are not
uh
they are not
even a shift of our strength so
they are not an option um
okay so this is the first application
for another application is location
sensitive encryption
in here
roughly speaking we show how we can
build a method to encrypt messages so
that only
people which are physically close to us
will be able to decry to decrypt
this is the second application and and
another application is to homomorphic
secret sharing
so
aeromorphic secretion allows many
[Music]
solving many problems uh
and and one thing about it that it it
usually have
a low communication complexity
so we show how
how by using a
high dimensional lphs say two
dimensional phs we can get even less
communication in in in protocols using a
more fixed
secret sharing
so
these are the applications
and now let us talk how we build
efficient lphs
so one solution to the problem is the
statue of liberty
uh solution we we've seen earlier
so in this solution
we just seek for
this we read the say d bits from the
input
and find
the most special
substring
in what we read
so for example we may search for the
largest streak of zeros
and
and output this location
so this is a valid lphs
but we want a better lphs
for this
how can i ask a question
so maybe i missed something maybe i
missed something but don't you need some
other
property of this hash function
to make it non-trivial
some is it pseudorandom or
otherwise like the constant zero
function would just
uh us so we want to identify a location
inside our stream
[Music]
and we want that after shifting
our string by say one
then we will stop on the same location
if you always output the zero location
you will end up on two different places
because one of the places is i
understand but i didn't see that in the
definition we did
[Music]
but okay maybe
[Music]
okay so i want to introduce a magic
trick
that
gives the
the essence of
our construction
so you should pick
a one card at the top row
and then advance by the number on the
car card that you see so if you choose
the three on the topo then you should
count three cards and repeat this
procedure
um
now
now we can do this but i will tell you
that every
no matter what card you pick you will
always end up at the at this location at
the
last row
um
so this is a magic trick and the
relation to lphs is that
that
we found it
that we find a distinguished location
inside our string of cards
by reading only a few
by looking at only a few
cards
so this is the essence of the
of our construction
and in the paper we show both
a good construction and also
a construction that we conjecture to be
optimal
and we prove the optimality of
of our conjectured optimal
um
construction
and just
to to open problems
so first the first
obvious open problem is to prove that
our two-dimensional lphs that we
construct is indeed optimal
and we can we didn't manage to
rigorously prove it
and moreover
if we go to higher dimensions then we do
not know to construct
nearly optimal lphs this is related to
that that two random walks in five
dimensions
are unlikely to collide
thank you
[Music]
okay thank you thank you very much any
other questions we have uh
one minute
um maybe i also say you didn't mention
the author so i want to mention them so
this is with a little
bit gilbert
and nathan keller
[Music]
so any other questions
okay did they miss something in chat
no
okay
so the next next speaker
uh probandum is that you
yes
yeah yes okay i don't know who the
speakers are and i'm just guessing it by
the way ourselves
um
okay so pavanjam
uh yeah so you can introduce the authors
and then the stage is yours
all right um so
hey everyone i'm going to talk about
preconceived encryption this is a joint
work with abhishek jain uh zheng zhang
jin and julia malavonta
um so this talk is about end-to-end
encryption systems um so we in into
encryption systems we have every pair of
users having a decryption key associated
with them they transmit ciphertext on
some platform owned by some organization
um so the question is you know the users
use the secret keys who generates a
secret key
so there are two options either the user
could generate the secret key or the
organization could generate the secret
key right
so it turns out that there are issues
with either the user generating the
security or the organization generating
the secret key so let's look at the
issues
so the user generates a secret key then
the you know law enforcement agencies
might not have access to the encrypted
data um so for example let's say this
user is suspected of some criminal
activity and they need the encrypted
data to um
file charges against this individual
then
then they won't be able to do so
so another issue is that uh you know
let's say the encrypted tests are on the
cloud and the server wants to do some
computation on it and sort of freak out
the answer
um then it's unclear how to accomplish
this uh in a non-interactive manner
right so it makes the
whole computing or encrypted data are
more interactive
the other hand you can think maybe like
the organization generates a secret key
but the problem is that this uh makes it
vulnerable to data reach attacks
um so a bunch of hackers could sort of
hack into the servers and steal all the
user keys
another issue is that you know maybe the
law enforcement agencies could force the
organization to reveal the secret keys
and perhaps use this to conduct mass
surveillance
um so this has led to the encryption
database where we have on the one hand
uh users and privacy advocates
uh advocating for the fact that we need
end-to-end encryption
and on the other end of the spectrum we
have you know senators congress men and
women and law enforcement officials who
want to abolish and do an encryption
so the question is you know is there a
middle ground can you come up with a
solution that can sort of satisfy both
these uh different groups
so towards addressing this very very
complex issue we're going to take a baby
step uh we're going to uh propose the
notion called preconceived encryption
um so in preconceived encryption it's
the authority is going to generate the
secret key except that the secret key is
going to have very limited decryption
power
uh so meaning that it can only recover
some very restricted amount of
information about the underlying message
so what does this restricted information
mean so let me take an example
suppose let's say the encrypted the
message being encrypted contains some
some potential incriminating uh content
let's say it says let's rob a bank then
using the secret key should be able to
recover and see what this message is
on the other hand if it contains
something innocuous like i'm attending
itcs then you should not be able to sort
of decrypt and recover uh what the
message contains
and one important point i want to
mention here is that there is no
assumption on the authority being honest
um so the authority could be generating
the secretary however it wants and we
want the
the generated secret key to still have
limited decryption power even if it's
even if it is generated maliciously
okay so let's look at the formal
definition
uh so the definition we have the setup
algorithm that takes this input a
constraint circuit see i'm going to talk
about what this is and it outputs a
secret key and above the key
so what is this constraint circuit c um
so this circuit c sort of partitions the
class of all functions
uh into two categories in the one
category we have the authorized set
these are all the functions
uh such that the output of the
constraint circuit on these functions
gives one is the output
and on the other category is called
unauthorized set
so um we should think of the authorized
set as follows uh given the decryption
key
anyone can recover uh a function of the
encrypted message
for any function in this author asset
so and for all the functions that are in
the unauthorized side you should not be
able to sort of recover the output of
the function of the message
okay so some classes of functions that
you can consider is you know these
functions you know there are broadly two
categories that you can consider uh in
one category you can have uh the
functions deciding whether the input
contains some objectionable material
maybe it could contain some
um you know sort of
outputs one if the input contains some
commonly used code words by criminals or
it could contain some illicit materials
like it can classify whether the
underlying message contains it or not
right in the other category yeah you
know maybe the input is like an email
message and
the function sort of classifies whether
it is spam or not
okay so let's go back to the definition
so we have the setup that outputs the
security in the public key then you have
the encryption algorithm this is the
standard
and in the decryption algorithm in in
addition to the decryption key you also
take as input
ciphertext and the function f
uh and the output of the decryption
algorithm should be f of x uh if and
only if f is authorized in other words
the output of the constraint circuit on
f outputs one
okay so one very useful feature to have
uh is the key delegation feature so we
can append the sort of algorithms that i
mentioned in the previous slide with
an algorithm called key generation
algorithm this takes this input
a secret key and and also the function
and outputs a functional key associated
with f
this is similar to
the key generation algorithm
you might have encountered in the
advanced encryption systems
and the decryption algorithm now takes
this input like a functional key and is
the ciphertext and outputs f of x
where f is authorized
so we want this uh pre-constrained
encryption system to satisfy three
properties so one is correctness um
should be able to recover f of x as long
as it is authorized
and the second property is uh security
against authority uh which says that you
know
even if the authority has this set up
randomness even if it has a secret key
should not be able to recover focus for
any unauthorized death
and finally we have the constraint
heading property uh that says that the
public key should not reveal any
information about the constrained
circuit c
so uh we have a bunch of results in the
paper so i'm sort of going to summarize
it at a high level now
uh so we give a set of definitions for
pre-constraint encryptions and we give
security compilers uh so if we first
look at pre-constraint encryption
satisfying something called a
semi-malicious security and we show how
to sort of boost it to malicious
security
uh using a general compile by proposing
a general compiler
and then we give constructions of
special cases of pre-constrained
encryption from learning with errors
um and then like we show that the most
general case of preconstrained
encryption is as powerful as io and even
some special cases such as like
attribute pre-constrained encryption
implies uh witness encryption
okay
so for the rest of the talk uh i'm going
to look at the special case which is
attribute based preconceived encryption
uh for point constraints um so these are
the two terms i haven't uh defined so
let me go and let me do that
so um
attribute pre-constraint encryption um
you know it's associated with the class
of functions that
you would encounter in an attribute
based encryption scheme um so so every
function
um is parameterized by another function
let me call the t it takes us input x
and m and outputs m if and only if the
parameterized function g on x output
zero
um and
by point constraint what i mean is that
the constraint circuit is parameterized
by an input x star
and the authorized set consists of all
the functions that output one on x dot
okay so it's a very specific class of
constraints
okay so let's see how to construct this
so here is the main insight
we observe that
the there are advanced encryption
systems in the crypto literature
uh with a very special security proof
structure
and we are going to look at this very
specific proof structure and we will
show how to sort of convert that into a
construction of preconceived encryption
okay so in more detail you know we have
the selective
security proof which of the structure
where the challenger the adversary needs
to declare the challenge message ahead
of time and then the challenger gives
the public key and then the adversary
can make a bunch of key queries
so in some security proofs
you reach a hybrid experiment
where the challenge challenger
uh computes a fake public key and a fake
secret key in such a way that the fake
secret key cannot issues for or cannot
issue keys for inadvisable functions
so what is inert visible depends on the
specific notion of advanced encryption
system that you consider
um so in our context you should think of
inadmissible functions as unauthorized
functions
so using this uh here is a template to
construct property constraint encryption
the setup algorithm takes us and put the
point cons point x dot and it outputs
the fake secret key in the public key
and the key generation algorithm can
issue keys if and only if uh f is
admissible or authorized right so even
if if is unauthorized then even if it
wants to it won't be able to generate a
key for it
um and we show how to construct this by
looking at the proof structure of uh
attribute based encryption scheme by
bone at all so i won't have
time to go into the details of the
construction so i'm gonna skip the
details
yeah you need to wrap up
yeah okay um so
uh there this is still a uh
nascent area and there are a lot of
interesting questions um so one natural
question is whether you know there are
many advanced encryption systems on the
literature can we look at the different
selective security proofs they have and
convert that into pc constructions we
need to still understand the
relationship of pre-constraint
encryption with advanced encryption
systems better
um also identify interesting class of
cons constraints based on the different
applications of pc
with the second load
okay thank you for banjon uh we don't
really have time for questions except if
somebody has like a really nice question
i'm giving three seconds
two one okay
and so the next talk is it's vika you're
welcome to share your screen
speakers gonna
tell us about
broadcast encryption
all right and why we can and cannot
achieve it
great are you seeing my screen
yeah
excellent good so i'm going to talk
about lattice inspired broadcast
encryption and 16 ciphertext policy abe
and this is joint work with vinod vegeta
nathan
let me start briefly saying what
broadcast encryption is so um we're
thinking about a content provider and it
wants to provide content to many users
so capital end users and um not all the
content is supposed to be visible to all
the users so you want to encrypt the
content so that only
permitted users will be able to decrypt
it so each user is associated with a
secret key so user x has secret key sk
sub x and we have an authorized set s of
users and we want to generate encryption
ciphertext with respect to the
authorized set
and um of course the notion of security
that we want this is standard and
cryptographic
constructions applications is this
notion of collusion resist resilience so
that not only each individual um an
authorized user cannot decrypt even if
some unauthorized users come together
and join all their secret keys together
they still should not be able to decrypt
the ciphertext
and
now the question that we ask how long
should the ciphertext be so we assume
that the authorized set itself is known
to everybody and the question is how
much additional information we need to
add
and there's a trivial solution to just
sort of encrypt the content and times
one well for each user and then each
user can decrypt its own secret key and
this is fine uh but obviously we want
much better dependence on the on the
size the author i set in particular or
on the side on the number of users in
particular we want to go all the way
down to polylogarithmic in the number of
users
um and uh
i guess uh um actually elon put it very
nicely in his in his introduction uh
there's there's a bunch of known
solutions but we actually don't really
know of
i don't know of a solution
that is provable under a post-quantum
assumption in particular so we want to
be resilient against quantum attacks and
one of the popular ways to do that is to
rely on lab assumptions in particular
learning with errors and a lot of
problems have been solved in this way so
we were able to show it was possible for
the community to show a lot of um
advanced cryptographic primitives based
on the hardness of the learning with
errors problem and somehow broadcast
encryption doesn't seem very different
um and yet we don't really know actually
i don't know how to do anything sort of
uh better than trivial um
from from lwe
um and this is sort of um sort of an
outstanding problem maybe this is the
sort of the last advanced primitive
that we have like
short of the regime of obfuscation that
we don't know how to construct from from
lwe
and i should say that you can actually
extend this problem and talk about this
ciphertext policy abe
which is essentially the same problem
except instead of an authorized set you
have an authorized policy like a
function f that tells you which user is
supposed to decrypt and which user is
not supposed to decrypt
and this is sort of the context that i'm
going to talk about
and so vinod and i were thinking about
this thing and how we should be able to
do it and we were sort of putting some
stuff together and we came up with
construction
um and we thought it was based on lwe
and all we need to do is to prove it but
we didn't manage to prove it
and so we said oh okay we sort of led
ourselves to believe so many times
before that we had construction for
something from lwe and we ended up
breaking it so we tried to break it and
we couldn't break it um and it's been a
while and um
you know we think that it's time for
other people to try to either prove it
or break it
so
this is what we uh sort of uh putting
forth in in this work so it's slightly
inspired in the sense that it was
inspired by what we know about uh
lattice and eliability-based
constructions
um we don't have a proof of security uh
we don't even have like a closed form
assumption under which we can prove the
um
the security of the scheme but also we
don't have we don't have attacks and we
also sort of
know why the attacks that work in other
cases so why when you try to sort of use
similar techniques to construct sort of
obfuscation related um primitives um you
have some attacks and these attacks
don't seem to work here but really this
is this is sort of all we have um
and uh yeah so we think that this could
be a starting point uh towards uh you
know trying to find a proof or trying to
find an attack uh
there's no reason for this not to be
possible to do either one
uh so this is similar to how io started
right with the candidate construction
reduction of proof and and look what it
did
right but yeah but then then like there
was a there was both i guess attempts to
prove and also uh viable attacks here
we're kind of at a standstill so um it's
really
i mean it's really interesting what is
the situation here maybe it is like it
would turn out that broadcast encryption
is somehow more similar to um uh
obfuscation related uh primitives even
though this is not the case from other
assumptions so really um curious um and
uh uh
i think there's uh there's
there's a lot left to be studied here uh
let me say just a few words about our
technique
it's our starting point so remember i
said that what we construct is
ciphertext policy attribute based
encryption uh and actually there is a
way to construct like sort of the
opposite there's no way to construct
sort of the opposite primitive which is
called key policy attribute
attribute-based encryption so think
about this as like the ciphertext is
associated with like some identity of a
user or something and um we um and we
give out secret keys that correspond to
permitted or not permitted functions
um so this can be done uh succinctly and
what we're trying to do is sort of turn
it turn it over uh on its head and and
sort of reverse the functionality that
the scheme gives you without sacrificing
succeeds so you can you can do it very
easily if you sacrifice succinctness but
this is what we're trying to do we're
trying to sort of um minimize the
ciphertex length so um
very briefly we're sort of using the
structure of the scheme so essentially
um what we're trying to do is sort of
take the decryption the encryption
procedure here so here the encryption
procedure is associated with this value
x and in what we want to construct we
want the secret key to be associated
with the with the identity with the
identity x so what we're trying to do is
make uh sort of a generic encryption
procedure which is good for all possible
x's and then in the decryption i'm going
to give you a secret key that's
associated with x that is only going to
allow you to sort of recover um the
cipher text that corresponds to like the
the key policy cipher texas corresponds
to x and then you will be able to sort
of run the run the decryption so this is
the way that we turn it uh we try to
turn it on its head
and the structure of the ski policy um
um abe
seems very useful for this because it
actually doesn't use x you can think
about it it's actually not using the
identity of x until sort of the last
steps so you generate like two times n
ciphertext pieces and then according to
x you just select one out of each pair
so what we do so let me sort of skip uh
uh some of the details that i have here
on here on the slide what we do when we
try to construct ciphertext policy
essentially generate all these two times
n pieces and
lock each one of them with an individual
lock
and we're going to try to generate a
secret key for x that will allow you to
unlock the pieces that are associated
with x so you're going to be able to
recover the correct cipher text but it
shouldn't allow you um it shouldn't
allow you not just to unlock the pieces
that you're not supposed to unlock but
remember we need to be resilient to
collusion so even if we have you know
some different users each one with an
unauthorized secret key then each one of
them can
you know
unlock
different pieces but these pieces are
going to be unlocked in different ways
so they're not going to be compatible so
if you unlock this piece with one key
and this piece with another key you're
not going to be able to put them
together and this is the structure that
we're trying to construct and we're
using the linear algebraic structure of
these schemes so essentially the
decryption for the key policy abe should
can be thought of as sort of matrix
multiplication on the right and the
unlocking procedure we're going to
generate it as a procedure of
multiplying by vector on the left so you
can do both of these things together and
if you do it many times with many
different keys then you're going to get
things that are incompatible so this is
like at a super high level
and yeah the question is whether it
whether it actually works or not so this
is what i have for you today thanks
okay thank you zika any questions
um so i would maybe ask like uh so maybe
broadcast encryption is like a heavy
primitive maybe that explains why it's
so hard to construct
like do we know that it implies
something
interesting except of encryption
so again it's it's not so heavy i mean
uh uh
you can you can do non-trivial things
even just not just even base based on
bilinear maps uh which is not like an
extraordinary okay i guess depends who
you ask but it's it's it's possibly not
an extraordinary assumption so uh i mean
i mean even getting just like a
polynomial improvement uh is something
that we don't know out of lattices so i
don't know if brought if you can sort of
say generically that broadcast
encryption is a hard problem maybe it's
somehow incompatible with what we know
how to do from lattices this is sort of
more like what's going on here although
you know i'm not sure
yeah so uh from bilinear maps we know
how to do like snugs and stuff like that
and
and this is also something we do not
know how to do from lattices right
or maybe
okay yeah
if there's a connection or not i don't
know i don't know
on top of that there's this recent
bilinear maps plus lwe based stuff
related to broadcast encryption and
again there they seem to be making some
sort of knowledge assumption on the
bilinear maps related to snargs right so
it does feel somehow like far away in
that sense
okay i mean i can i can say that the
that construction that alex was was
alluding to by um agarwal uh and yamada
and wix i guess um it actually uses like
a similar structure except this instead
of multiplying on the left they're
multiplying on the left and the exponent
of a linear group and uh this this
allows you to actually sort of get uh
get a provable get approval construction
which is sort of a very uh very nice way
of using the linear maps i thought
okay slicker thank you we're
one minute over time so we're just gonna
move on
so our next speaker is alex
and then he's going to talk about
correlation tractable
hash functions and this is also what we
node
um
and alexi one
okay uh you can see the slide
okay
uh hey everyone thanks for coming i'll
be talking about this joint work with
the node on correlation and tractable
hash functions via shift hiding
so what is correlation and tractability
uh it's a very general purpose security
property of a hash function or hash
function family
you can think of it as being
parameterized by a relation r
which takes 2 which takes our t inputs x
1 through x t along with t corresponding
outputs y1 through yt that's that's what
the relation r is and a hash function
family h is correlation intractable for
r
if it is computationally difficult to
find an r correlation in this hash
function meaning it's hard to come up
with inputs x 1 through x t
such that x 1 through x t and y 1
through y t satisfy the relation where y
i is equal to hash of x i so that it's
in that sense that the you have a
correlation inside the hash function uh
so
this is an extremely broad security
property uh and
for the most part we do not know how to
instantiate this based on a standard
cryptographic assumption uh like
in in many cases a random oracle will
satisfy this property as long as r
satisfies the correct notion of sparsity
but using an actual hash family we don't
know too much
so
we do know something if you limit the
scope extremely in two different ways
i
if you set t to be one
and you set relations to be functions
then we know something so in this very
special case we're just saying
you know we have correlation and
tractability for functions which means
that it's difficult to find a single
input x such that hash of x equals f of
x where f is some pre-specified function
uh so this
we know how to build from recent work we
know how to build it from standard
assumptions in particular uh due to this
work of ficond and xi and we know how to
do it based on just a plain learning
with errors assumption
so this is this is what we know
i should also mention that you know
collision resistance is a special case
of the more general correlation
interactability definition and somehow
these two examples sort of
describe everything that we know for the
most part uh about the general
definition
okay so that's correlation and
tractability uh so why do we care
so there are a few reasons to care
in the single input case uh correlation
and tractability turns out to be very
closely tied to instantiating what's
called the theatromir heuristic and the
standard model fiat premier heuristic is
a methodology for building
non-interactive argument systems from
interactive proofs or interactive
arguments even
and there is this very nice line of work
from the last few years that has done
two things it has
reduced
instantiating fiat chamier to
various special cases of correlation and
tractability
and then two it has built the sufficient
correlation and tractability for those
applications and this has resulted in a
bunch of nice non-interactive protocols
so that's for the single input case
in the multi-input case
i would say that things are quite less
well studied but there are a few
applications pretty intriguing
applications that people already know
about uh just quickly you know it seems
related to building an untrusted common
random string you know with that like
by where you have many parties
submitting inputs that will contribute
to an untrusted crs it turns out to be
also related to uh the security of
uh like of various mpc protocols i
i have bitcoin as an example on the
slide where where a form of multi input
correlation and tractability is a
necessary but i mean not sufficient but
necessary condition for for a hash
function that you use in the bitcoin
protocol
and finally there's this very cool work
of offer justin and aylon recently that
uses a form of two input correlation
interactability to build a very nice
computationally
like sound error correcting code which i
thought was pretty nice so these are
just a few examples of multi-input
correlation and tractability even doing
something i expect that there are lots
of things that it can do but it's
not very well studied
uh so the the question for this talk is
how we build this object uh and and what
we do in this work is we give a new
framework for building correlation and
tractability by using this other object
from the crypto which you know is a
priori completely unrelated called shift
hiding shiftable functions uh this is
introduced by picard and xi'an a few
years ago
and they were trying to use it to build
constrained prfs that was the goal
uh and so so what's what does our
framework do so first of all it gives a
new construction of single input
correlation and tractability for
functions from lwe that's extremely
simple
the proof is sort of like two lines so
it's very nice
it also allows us to build new flavors
of multi-input correlation and
tractability from lwe
and then even more flavors of
multi-input correlation and tractability
additionally assuming obfuscation
so yeah this is roughly speaking what we
do so an example so here's an example
results from that second category um
you can consider the following kind of
relation which we called a shifted
linear relations so it's parametrized
just by a function f
and the relation is a collection of t
inputs and outputs where the outputs the
y i they add up to the sum of f x i
over all of the inputs
so you know you have the inputs you
evaluate f on them and the the relation
is satisfied if the out if though yeah
the y i sum up to f x i
so one thing that we can do is build
correlation and tractable hash functions
for this relation so it's hard to find t
inputs
whose corresponding hash outputs add up
to the sum of f x i over all i
and uh you can extend this to for
example also to like weighted linear
combinations
so here's an example sort of thing that
we can build in the multi-input setting
um so the main objects that we use to
build this stuff is shift hiding
shiftable functions and you should think
of this as sort of like a prf with a
programmability property so
so uh so the the syntax is on the slide
and so the point is that there should be
a way to take your prf key and output a
shifted key depending on some function
that sort of shifts the whole evaluation
of the prf by f so the shifted
evaluation of x should always be the
real evaluation plus f of x or at least
it should be hard to find an input where
this is not true and then and then the
shifted key should hide the function so
this is the basic object and before any
of this stuff building correlation and
tractability from standard assumptions
we already knew how to build this from
lwe this was already known
um and so now there's like so for the
like main idea behind what's going on in
this paper and i'll just like show you
what it is in the single input setting
it generalizes immediately to the
multi-input setting so the key lemma is
that a shift hiding shift of a function
should just give you correlation and
tractability like as long as it
satisfies a minor additional property so
it's a it's a sort of self-reduction for
correlation and tractability so so the
construction is
given the shift-heading shifts of a
function you should define your hash
function to just be a shifted evaluation
of this function the shifted evaluation
on like a trivial constrained key so
it's just you know constrained it's
constrained to shift zero so it's it
should be matching the action like the
actual prf
and the claim is that
this thing should be correlation and
tractable for all f provided that the
original shift hiding shift of a
function is harder to invert at zero so
it's sort of like a one wayness property
like that you need to assume in addition
to the shift hiding property and if it
holds then you just get correlation and
tractability for free
so this is yeah as i was saying so the
shift hiding property just gives you a
way to reduce
general
kind of correlation and tractability to
an extremely simple case namely here the
cases literally f being the all zero
function
um
so this raises a interesting question
another interesting question which has
come up before which is you know given
just some prf uh imagine that the prf
secret key is actually given out in the
clear uh can you say anything about the
prf in particular can you say that it's
like a one-way function so this has been
studied a little bit in the past and it
comes up again here which i thought was
an interesting connection um and so the
proof of this lemma is like is trivial
it's total logical just like
just like shifts the key and stare at
what happens and the proof comes out in
two lines so it's very nice
um so then the only thing left to do in
the single input case at least is then
to just
you know see if we have uh an shsf that
actually satisfies this one witness
property and it turns out that the
the construction that was already known
actually satisfied this property so we
already had correlation and tractability
even before we tried to construct it it
turns out i won't give you the proof
here of this one witness property it but
it's it's like
a new like uh it's a new proof like in a
like large family of proofs just
manipulating these bgg plus style
homomorphisms uh so i i think it's uh
and uh
so
we extend this in order to get
multi-input results we show that this
object is also for example collision
resistant and more generally satisfies
this property that it's hard to find a
bunch of inputs
uh such that you know when you hash the
inputs and take some fixed weighted
linear combination that you get zero
this is the like base property that you
need it's sort of it's like a
slight generalization of collision
resistance which can then be like lifted
to get these f dependent correlation and
tractability properties
so that's all i wanted to say uh there
are a bunch of nice open problems i
think that that's our you know related
to this namely can we actually rely on
weaker assumptions than lwe to get
correlation and tractability and like
exactly like what kinds of multi-input
correlation and tractability can we
really reason about uh that's it thanks
for listening
okay thank you alex
any questions
um okay so thanks again that was very
interesting and i would really want to
know how we can do multi-input collision
factor build for like searchable
relations something like we know how to
do for one input i think that would be
very nice
um
that
finishes up our session
and uh there's another session that just
starts started two minutes ago in room b
you're all welcome
and there's another crypto session
tomorrow for the crypto people so i hope
to see you there
bye guys